uh Tom angel says this Neal do you agree
with Carl Sagan and yeah us voters hey
Tom there's there's your pantsuit ah
there's your answer okay I'm very little
I disagree with and guess what I'm gonna
go ahead and say that look quite now we
got to know I want to know now you
wouldn't have to that marijuana should
be legalized Oh
[Applause]
yeah whoa
so I think if you really analyze it
relative to other things that are
illegal there's no reason for it to ever
have been made illegal in the leak in
the system of laws that is extremely
rational which I expect from you and
you're absolutely right yeah I mean
alcohol is legal and it could mess you
up way more than smoking a few J yeah so
boy everything's up I can tell you that
never smoke weed your life and you just
like smoking a few J's you look like a
beefy after-school person
are you smoking a few genes yeah it's a
left one I was like in a cloud of it
that's that's house people spoke okay
right on okay all right let's do one
quick one because oh by the way by the
way it's just funny because if you want
to sound like Mickey Mouse you inhale
the helium from the helium balloon okay
but the way you do that is you untie the
knot Inigo it's so right right exactly
the in other words when kids are at a
party sharing helium balloons they might
as well be smoking some
[Laughter]